more and more people are waking up to
the woke left wing madness
because of this maybe you now believe or
have even done
something that the utes in their right
wing lingo
might call based this can be a very
confusing event for people
who thought that they were liberal so i
am here to help you sort it all out
and help you see where you land are you
conservative curious
or are you a full-blown knuckle-dragging
salt-sewing red-pilled based
conservative
other people use rankings like s t or a
t or b tier
we've got very different categories the
lowest tier
of basedness is you think men are not
women
that's kind of entry level the next
level you secretly voted for trump
in 2020. you're a little more committed
but you know you kind of keep your head
down you don't you don't want to make
too much noise
in the third tier you're pretty bought
in you can't help but make comments now
and again to get you in trouble
this is where your blue haired cousin
doesn't talk to you
at the next level you flaunt your
patriotism
you are like the florida man who waved
an american flag in a hurricane which is
actually a violation of flag code but
your heart's in the right place and then
finally the s tier the top
baster than genghis khan which is when
you're already banned on every social
media platform
those are the five categories men are
not women secretly voted for trump
blue hairs won't talk to you hurricane
flag
social media exile before we begin this
video is sponsored by ring
no matter your home ring has everything
you need to protect it more from them
in a minute let's get started wearing a
maga hat
out in public so obviously it's it's
past the second tier the second tier is
you secretly voted for trump
now you're at the your blue hair cousin
won't
speak to you anymore are you all the way
up to waving a flag in a hurricane
probably not you know
trump did win the election malarkey
certainly won the election the first
time and
a whole lot of people voted for him the
second time 70 million
more than 70 million who knows so i
think you're probably at
your blue haired cousin won't speak to
you but you're not yet at the point
where you're risking life in len
to wave old worry you got the don't
tread on me bumper sticker
okay this is actually kind of a
surprising one
i'm going to say
i'm going to say it's the same level
it's it's more commitment the don't
tread on me
is pretty hardcore you're saying i don't
just want to go back to good old america
but i want to go all the way back to
that kind of revolutionary spirit
1776 baby but it's also appropriated by
a lot of like libertarians some people
who
don't necessarily love trump but you
know they're very ideological
so i'm going to say this is still not
quite waving the flag in the hurricane
but your blue haired cousin
definitely does not like you applied to
joint space force
now you're getting a little bit higher
up here
you probably haven't been banned on all
the social media platforms because i
assume you'll need some internet access
to
apply to space force but if you're if
you're willing to launch yourself
into the cold abyss for the glory of
your country
in a department that was started by
donald trump you
you would wave a flag in a hurricane
you've got the american flag emoji in
your twitter handle
okay if you've got the flag emoji in
your twitter handle
you definitely voted for trump and that
is public
so now you're you're definitely past the
first two
tiers are you willing to wave the flag
in a hurricane maybe maybe not or you
banned on social media obviously not
because you still have a twitter handle
so i'm going to peg this conservatively
at you know you're willing to signal the
flag you're willing to wave the flag on
social media which can be very dangerous
these days i'm not sure if you're
willing to do it
in the hurricane so your blue haired
cousin does not like you
you can name all of the american
presidents that just makes you a nerd
[Music]
that doesn't that does not make you
conservative necessarily
i guess if you have any even relatively
strong grasp of american history
i guess by definition that makes you
conservative in this day and age
but this is a little bit lower i mean
you know that men are not women probably
if you can name all the presidents
did you secretly vote for trump yeah
yeah you probably did
i'm not even totally willing to i'd say
this is kind of the first level
at the very least you know men are not
women
you participate in the nose mask protest
yeah so this is certainly you know men
are not women certainly you know
that you shouldn't wear filthy cloth on
your face in public because that's
disordered and you look like a lame
bandito
it's a science experiment is that a
category maybe not
you definitely secretly voted for trump
uh it i guess the question is is
are you secretly voting for trump or are
you
your blue haired cousin won't speak to
you anymore i guess it depends if you
have seen your blue haired cousin with
the face mask probably knowing the blue
her cousin she's
not going to leave her apartment during
this whole thing unless it's to go to
the dispensary or something so
probably this is you secretly voted for
trump
but you're not willing to wave that flag
in the hurricane because
you haven't even ripped the whole thing
off yet you're just kind of below here
you know then you got to start moving it
down a little further you get
my favorite one is when you wear the
mask on your chin that's my favorite
protest you can sort of tell someone's
politics by how low on their face
they wear the mask you are
anti-mask so this just means that you
have two brain cells to rub together
actually
uh so yeah you're you're a little bit
conservative here you don't want to let
the exalted duck devouchy uh run
roughshod over our entire
country in civilization here we go again
so you know that men are not women for
sure
did you secretly vote for trump yeah i
guess you did does your blue haired
cousin hate you
she does yeah would you wave the flag
in the hurricane well it depends like
are you are you saying you're so
anti-mask
that you wouldn't wear it even if the
cops are yelling at you
you're gonna get arrested on an airplane
or something if that's the case then
obviously
you know you're going way up the chain
but if you're just generally speaking
anti-mask probably just
you know you're at the phase where where
the blue hairs don't like you very much
the patriot is your favorite movie this
you know
the pastry is an excellent movie some
people think it's a little overwrought
but it's
it's a great movie you obviously know
that men are not women you obviously
voted for trump
at least secretly you might be able to
play it safe enough
that you stay on social media that you
don't get blown away in a hurricane and
that your cousin still will come to
dinner with you so i'm gonna say you
know
it's good you've got great taste in
movies though you should you should
check out
other great movies like i don't know me
myself and irene or other sort of
brilliant brilliant films
but still patriot very good movie this
is where you secretly voted for trump
so much is going on at our front doors
these days that's one thing that
definitely has not changed okay it is
more important than ever
to be able to see who is there and what
is happening especially for me
these days i got a lot of people coming
to my house sometimes it's
food delivery because we don't want to
cook we got that newborn baby we're all
very busy
sometimes it's people dropping off gifts
for the baby sometimes it's in-laws they
want to see the baby
depending on which one that is you're
going to maybe open the door or you're
going to pretend to be still and not let
anybody in
either way you've got to check out ring
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door
whether you are in your bedroom maybe
you're at the office maybe you are on a
beach somewhere on the other side of the
world
ring will bring you there it's very
futuristic it's very very cool makes a
great housewarming gift
because it's high quality and not that
expensive so you get credit for a good
gift but you don't have to shell out a
lot i really like it
makes me feel safe when i'm traveling i
know sweet little elisa and cute little
june can know who's at the door before
they open it
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit right now ring.com knowles
comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
chime pro the perfect way
to upgrade your front door and start
your ring experience ring.com
knowles that is ring.com slash knowles
back to the tears okay you actively
discriminate against french people this
should be the default setting of all
americans and really all civilized
people
i in your general direction i'm not even
sure this means that you secretly
voted for trump i think this is an even
more basic
common sense position than that
your goldfish is named goldwater
you're pretty committed uh so you
secretly voted for trump for sure
well hmm this is tricky because there's
a kind of
group of conservatives kind of like the
never trumpers who are like
oh yeah man if i lived back in the barry
goldwater days i would have totally been
conservative
oh yeah if i lived back in the reagan
days i would have been totally
conservative
but now they're just like super squishy
and liberal you know they're like i'm a
conservative but not that kind of
conservative
and they they basically hide in the sort
of halcyon conservative days of the past
rather than having the courage to fight
the actual battles we're in now
so i'm actually going to peg that one
down a little bit you know that men are
not women
maybe you did not secretly vote for
trump
you still want jane fonda tried for
treason yeah baby now we're talking it's
based
you definitely voted for trump but not
secretly you did it publicly
uh your cousin does not talk to you you
may be banned from social media if you
say things like we need to try her
because also you know the punishment for
treason is like not it's a little a
little tricky
[Music]
so yeah you're probably banned from
social media for that you're you're
cause
you're gonna hear a lot of people say
like we we want to hear all opinions
it's totally cool that jane fonda was
sitting at an anti-aircraft gun in
vietnam yeah no that's great oh
the marketplace of ideas or something uh
no no it's not she should definitely
definitely not have been permitted to do
that you're getting banned from social
media if you're if you're espousing that
youtube publicly
you own a firearm yeah so great great
great picture too
uh is that my blue haired cousin no no
definitely not definitely not
you own a firearm you know that men are
not women
you definitely secretly voted for trump
but the thing about firearms is like
voting for trump you can do it in secret
i know a lot of people who will come up
to me you know they kind of play nice
they're sort of
friends with lots of liberals and they
get invited to liberal parties but
secretly you know they're
they're second amendment supporters so
that one's gonna just be you secretly
voted for trump
you open carry for no reason whatsoever
yeah that's
that's a little bit higher up the chain
for sure
you probably would wave the flag in the
hurricane at that
at that moment when you've just got that
gun on your hip just to say
damn it i'm proud to be an american
you're getting out there with old glory
no doubt
you believe nixon did nothing wrong this
just means that you're smart
and reasonable and you don't get tricked
by the liberal media
okay
you would wave the flag in the hurricane
at that point for sure would you be
banned from social media
yeah like maybe because you're to to
recognize that
richard nixon basically just got ousted
because subversives lit actually in the
deep state
never forgave him for going after the
communist alger hiss
which is really what this whole thing
was about if you recognize that then you
probably challenge
a lot of the mainstream narratives
surrounding our politics
so i'm going to say you might be banned
on social media you're veering between
either waving the flag
or an outright ban depending on how
flamboyant you are
in your correct views blocked by
celebrities on twitter
these days you need to sneeze to get
blocked by celebrities on twitter that's
very
you you know that men are not women
that's about all it takes
that's like the basic level is getting
blocked by these
very trigger-happy celebrities you cut
your hair at great clips
i don't i don't know if i can quite
capture the political significance of
that
uh do you know i'm not sure that you
even need to know that men are not women
to get your hair cut at great clips i'm
uh i think this is going to be a special
secret tier that's not in our five tiers
i think this tier is
right below you knowing that men are not
women this is one where you just like a
great deal
and you know i think everybody can enjoy
a great deal even the libs
you bought gamestop stock and still
haven't sold
deep effing value is what you are
to quote a very famous reddit user i
mean you're waving that
flag in the hurricane no doubt and i
guess actually if you're one of the
if if you are deep effing value which is
the name of one of these very famous
users
you're you're definitely getting banned
on social media websites right i mean
you are
the whole the reddit one after these
guys twitter went after these guys like
everybody was going after
uh the wall street's bets guys who were
pumping up game stock to put the the
hedge funds that were short game stop
put the squeeze on them and make a ton
of money making fun of wall street
so that's that's pretty strong i guess
that's the top tier
you post all lives matter on blm videos
so that's good so it's not just saying
all lives matter
that would just be like you secretly
voted for trump this is a little more
provocative because you're going to the
blm videos
definitely your blue hair cousin doesn't
talk to you and you would you would wave
the flag
in the hurricane because if you're doing
that kind of stuff you are
putting yourself in physical danger just
as you would if you were waving the flag
in the hurricane
are you banned from social media well if
you're still posting on those videos i
guess you're not banned yet
so i would say you're you're at the
hurricane level
your boat sank at a trump rally yeah my
favorite trump rallies are the ones on
in newport beach on duffy boats or it's
just lots of
great middle-aged conservatives waving
those flags
i guess you're waving the flag in the
hurricane i mean it's it's actually
the best analogy to that scene because
you are actually going down
drowning in physical danger while waving
a flag
you've been featured in the comment of
the day on the michael knowles show man
that is
that is getting into top tier let's see
you oh if you're willing to be
featured on my show your cousin probably
doesn't talk to you
would you wave the flag yeah duh
are you banned from social media
obviously not yet not yet is the answer
you're still at the fourth deer but
probably once you're featured on my show
then
then you might be booting up to the
fifth tier you're on thin ice pal
you have a subscription to the daily
wire you know i actually have to say
having a subscription to the daily wire
i think it used to be like you
you had to be the most knuckle dragon
genghis khan ever but i
am really pleased as people are waking
up to this insane woke culture
that more people in the middle even some
lives are
coming over because they realize that if
they get their news from cnn and
new york times and washington post
they're just being lied to all the time
this is ridiculous
so i'm actually very pleased you don't
even think you needed to secretly vote
for trump i think
as long as you can acknowledge a very
like very basic facts about the world
the sky is blue two plus two is four men
are not women
if you're just that basic level you can
start
to enter into that space and then
hopefully we at the daily wire will take
you
all the way down all the way down the
path to make you a full-fledged
knuckle dragging conservative let me
know in the comments section if you
agree with my rankings
let me know any other topics you want me
to cover we'll see you next time
[Music]
you